sechrist a as you know it's a very
turbulent time in the world we've got
Syria Ukraine I got the migrant crisis
so why the oceans why are you devoting
so much energy to that because the
oceans are a security threat challenge
the state of the oceans are a security
challenge for everybody in the world
they are under siege by overfishing
which is a food challenge to people in
the world and an ecosystem breakdown
challenge they are polluted in many many
places than more than 500 dead zones in
the ocean now which will affect spawning
grounds in the future of the ecosystem
the oceans are rising due to climate
change and Siddha fying because of
climate change co2 goes into the water
and it metastases form becomes carbonic
acid as a profound impact on sea life so
the oceans are threatened we get fifty
percent of the oxygen that we breathe on
this planet from the oceans and we
should not play with them we need to be
respectful we need to do things to turn
the course around because life itself is
threatened and that's why we're taking
time to do this this is a life of death
an issue in the ways that other
challenges are also like I mean that
really is the question of whether we can
do anything about it course you can have
I mean take fishing I mean there are
lots of parts of the world the
Mediterranean is one example close to
the United Kingdom in Europe where it's
pretty much fished out can you get a
very problem the answer is yes you can
bring it back but you can't fish for a
while in order to do that we had that
problem in Massachusetts number of years
ago we lost our striped bass stock and
so we banned striped bass fishing for
ten years today there is a healthy stock
of striped bass people can go out
recreational fishers commercial
fisherman but it's done in a sustainable
way and the reason the Mediterranean is
where it is it wasn't done sustainably
so that's exactly what we're trying to
foster here is a sustainable approach a
sustainable ethic where you can fish but
you're doing it in a way where it's
allowed to replenish and be there for
the future they do you got the problem
enforcement as well
you have a huge problem with enforcement
and we will be announcing here a safe
ocean network that is going to put in
place modern technology to begin to do
the tracking of fishing efforts in
various parts of the world and as we
build that out and we hope to do it
rapidly we will gain better control over
who's fishing where and what their fight
a strong finish contribution to that I
believe likewise yes d the Great British
satellite friend did cut but we're also
you know we have the port state measures
when I started this conference in 2014
only twenty ten countries had signed up
to this protocol a treaty where you
would actually have restrictions on
people's ability to sell fish within a
port and they'd have to be able to prove
where they caught it that they were
licensed and it was appropriate and and
now there are 60 nations signed up for
this measure and it only took 25 to make
it become international law so we're
building this out we're trying to do
that in the context of this this
conference and will will continue let's
take plastics for a moment I mean
massive amount of plastic in the ocean
which ends up in digestive systems and
elsewhere some action on micro beads on
both sides of the Atlantic but here we
are for single use plastic bottles here
in the State Department of it can you
win that battle against plastics yes but
it takes responsible approach to it it
takes I mean we've done a lot as you
know with respect to recycling of
bottles there are a lot of products made
now with recycled fishnets and recycled
plastic and even clothing it's made in
some ways with some recycled plastic as
part of it so there are a lot of things
that we can do if we change the way
people think and and and their casual
practices you can't just throw it away
on the beach you can't just give me
people there have to be consequences for
actions now what we haven't talked about
yet is the whole question of global
warming certification which perhaps is
the climate change the biggest threat
you done what you could in
as yet we've got Donald Trump saying he
would cancel that initiative and
questioning the whole question of a
global warming won't be the impact on
the sort of things you're trying to do
if we ended up with a trump
administration well I'm not permitted to
engage in the politics so I can't start
taking sides one way or the other but
it's no secret that I believe very very
strongly in the science of climate
change and I believe today we have a
president United States Barack Obama who
has implemented major policies in order
to respond to the to the urgency of
climate change he has changed automobile
standards truck standards building
standards power plant emitting standards
put in place major initiative on climate
change and so forth climate action plan
for the country so I want that to
continue in the future and I hope the
American people will vote in a way that
reflects the urgency of these issues
because presumably your efforts here are
hampered by the fact that the United
States is not a signatory to the
convention on the law of the sea no well
I mean occasionally I run into a comment
or two about why aren't you in it but we
the reason we're not in it is we have a
united states senate that won't ratify
exactly the robotically administration
and the last administration before it
which was Republican made it clear they
would live by the law of the sea so
George W Bush his administration has
lived by the Obama administration is
lived by it and I hope the next
administration even if we can't ratify
it will continue to live by it not to
talk about the pressure pressures on the
Secretary of State at the moment or on
Hillary Clinton who was Secretary of
State do you think she's physically up
to the job God the stuff I am absolutely
convinced years but it's not my job to
get into this race so let's not be
asking about the candidates okay we got
it I've no doubt about her physical
stamina she's strong
you know but let's talk about the fishin
you know yeah what about Britain's role
in all this because there's perception
that perhaps now that Britain's voted
for Briggs it doesn't that carry the
cloud the influence that has in the
world I noticed that it well we're going
to have many Brits a junior minister
here today Britain insists that that
won't change I we have to see what
evolves I mean it's too early to tell we
were against brexit everybody knows the
United States of America thought it was
a mistake but now that it's been voted
on and passed the will of the people is
going to be implemented and respected
and we will respect it and try to find a
way forward that meets the security
needs and the trade needs the economic
needs of our relationships and that's
our that's our job that rose being a
breach between Europe and America
presume well maybe some of that and
maybe some bridging but we also have to
work out our own relationship with
whatever changes take place in Europe as
a result of this or whatever change
there is in the relationship between
Britain and Europe we don't know that
yet and we need to give them the space
to negotiate and work through the brexit
process David Cameron as you know his
quit politics this week what do you
think the verdict will be on his
international role bury my eye the
president for example saying he lost
concentration in Libya of I I again I'm
not going to get into the business of
commenting on
you know the former prime minister or
prime minister of another country or
that's not my job my job is to build the
bridges not tear them down and yeah but
it is a mess in Liberia and it's
affecting well Libya is getting yes it's
been a mess and President Obama himself
has publicly stated that he wishes that
he and others had focused more on the
aftermath of Libya and we've been
working extremely hard to bring the
Libyan government to a place of
legitimacy we made a lot of progress we
need to deal now still with some outlier
players who are not yet unified into the
government of national unity but I think
we're making progress we will have
meetings on that in New York next week
and I hope we can strengthen Libya two
quick questions Syria Britain America
wanted Assad to go it seems if there is
a settlement now he'll stay I have no
knowledge of a quote settlement or a
deal I certainly we have any Dale Adelia
working towards would let him stay no
this is something the Syrian people are
going to have to decide and something
the negotiations going to have to decide
our position is still that we don't see
how you can possibly make peace or how
there will be peace in Syria without
side still there because I think he is a
magnet who draws the jihadis who
attracts the conflict such as it is
today it's defined around Assad to a
certain degree and I don't see how he
makes up for barrel bombing as citizens
torturing the citizens gassiness
citizens I just don't see how that
happens but it's up to the Syrian people
to decide what will be the future of
Syria that will happen we hope when they
get to the negotiating table in Geneva
finally a reflective question you ran
for president you've ended up Secretary
of State after a long career in the
Senate do you think actually you can
influence the world more as US Secretary
of State than as president no I think
that the president united
it's is obviously the most powerful
position in our country certainly and
one of the most powerful in the world if
not d so obviously what I do as a
secretary of state i do with the
president who wants to do those things
and who licenses me to go out and do
those things so this is not
automatically inherently a powerful
position it has been powerful I think in
the last year's because the president
has trusted me he has empowered me and
he himself has adopted a set of
priorities which put us in sync and have
empowered us to be able to i think be
effective in afghanistan and in our
policy in ukraine trying to get the
implementation of Minsk and getting the
Iran agreement and getting the chemical
weapons out of Syria in working now on
Libya and Yemen and helping to bring
about a Paris agreement the rebalance to
Asia the TPP I think we've been able to
call you know the Ebola crisis and now
the Zika we've been able to be effective
because we have a president who is
engaged on a global basis thank you
thank you